I I have a passion for it mostly because
as I said this is not an abstraction for
me I got to know too many people on each
side i got to know too many people who
separate I got to see too many people
who in a sense fell victim to
hopelessness and frustration I saw the
price of the conflict in its human terms
and for me it wasn't acceptable
I don't know that there was a moment
where I achieved something but I can
tell you there were there was a
particular moment where I had mothers on
each side and Israeli mothers come to me
and say you have to succeed crying but I
had Palestinian mothers do it too and it
made me feel that I had a responsibility
not that I could take the place of the
two of them but if there was such a
desire to see it settled and somehow a
feeling that help from the outside could
play a pivotal role and I became the
kind of vehicle for that it made me feel
that I had a responsibility and I think
it's the first time i had an israeli
mother come to me literally crying and
you know holding my hands and pleading
with me to succeed it made me feel that
there was a larger responsibility here
and I couldn't you know that I had to
try to live up to